russia's invasion of ukraine is said to
dominate a meeting of g20 foreign
ministers the group of rich and
developing nations have begun their
talks on the indonesian island of bali
the countries involved are ones likely
to feel the effects of a food and energy
crisis that the war is setting off
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
opened his visit by holding talks with
his chinese counterpart wang yi wang is
also expected to meet face to face with
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
u.s china tensions remain high over
taiwan and trade disputes china has also
refused to condemn russia's invasion of
ukraine while the us is sending military
gear and other assistance to bolster
kiev's war effort
amid the tensions indonesian president
joko widodo has been trying to mediate
last week he visited both russia and
ukraine in what he described as a peace
mission here's more on indonesia's
unique stance on the war in ukraine
joko widodo has sought to maintain good
relations with both russia and ukraine
indonesia is what vladimir putin calls a
friendly nation for moscow
unlike any of the western powers
widodo has refused to give in to western
pressure to exclude vladimir putin from
the summit of g20 leaders in november
his visit to moscow and kiev last week
reflected a delicate balancing act
what i said in kiev i repeat here
though the current situation is still
hard we must keep opening more room for
dialogue i have conveyed a message from
president zielinski to president putin
and i express my readiness to become a
communication bridge between the two
leaders
the content of that message from
zalenski was not made public
widodo was the first asian leader to
visit kiev since the war began
he invited president zielenski to attend
the g20 leaders summit in november even
though ukraine is not part of the group
widodo has expressed sympathy with
ukrainians over the war and said the
country's territorial integrity must be
respected
prior to the meeting he toured the kiev
suburb of epeen to witness the
devastation first hand
indonesia is sending humanitarian aid to
ukraine but has declined to provide
weapons for use against russian forces
widodo came fresh from an international
summit in germany where he was able to
compare notes with western leaders and
meet with those who have previously
sought to persuade vladimir putin to end
the war indonesia has had success in the
past in mediating in regional conflicts
in asia but widodo says he has no
illusions about the complexity of the
russia ukraine war
and in a reminder of those complexities
zelensky hinted he would only attend the
g20 summit if putin is not there but the
kremlin says putin has already confirmed
his attendance
let's go to jakarta now and speak with
lena alexandra head of the international
relations department at the center for
strategic and international studies
welcome to dw news asia you were quoted
this week in malaysia's the star
newspaper as saying that joko widodo's
trip to ukraine was not a peace effort
so why did he go
well basically i think we need to
clarify first uh i think from the press
statements that the president made after
the meeting with the ukraine ukrainian
and president and also
the russian president i think it's quite
clear that there are several uh goals or
objectives of him going
to visit the europe
basically the first is to
reiterate or to emphasize the
invitations to most countries to attend
the g20 summit in november in bali
that's the first message
second
is of course to express the the the
empathy and also the concern regarding
the conflict uh the ongoing conflict
between russia and ukraine
and also
in that context he also mentions that he
is actually willing to be the the the
messenger
of a peace message um from the ukrainian
president to the russian president and
the third point i think this is very
very clear that
indonesia the indonesian president
expresses
the hope that
both countries can also can can return
to the global supply chain
where
the commodities from both countries
can uh
uh can can uh can go back to the global
super chain so it can actually avoid the
the crisis or the food crisis the energy
crisis uh that is actually um facing or
haunting
uh many states um
including in southeast asia okay you've
you've outlined possibly uh some of the
reasons i'm going to ask you on my next
question but if you could sort of go
into more detail as to why the war
matters to indonesia and more broadly to
southeast asia
well i think to some extent we need to
admit we need to recognize that the
in terms of geographical sense
that the conflict itself is quite remote
from the from the region but of course i
think it is very clear for everyone that
the implications of the war especially
in terms of the direct disruption of
global supply chain this is something
that really implicates the region very
much especially with the with the supply
of barley and also potassium to make
fertilizers things like that that really
implicates the region that is still
suffering from the impact of the coffee
19 panamix
talk to us about why is indonesia
choosing to stay neutral in this
conflict
well i think for
different reasons what i can say
i think it is very clear we recognize
ourselves that we don't really
we don't really have the capacity to be
the so-called peace mediator for example
but we are the country that actually um
yeah are implicated the most
uh from the impacts of of the war itself
as i mentioned earlier it is
for example indonesia is one of the
biggest importers of the
bali from ukraine for example so this is
something that we need to um
to deal with and that's why i think the
president needs to emphasize on this
that's one point
second point is definitely because
indonesia holds the position as the
president of the g20
and there is also an interest
to make sure
that we can secure
the g20 agenda later on in the summit
because of course we all know that there
has been issue that some countries might
uh not want to appear in the summit
later on so as a president i think
indonesia needs to make sure about this
do you think indonesia sees this too
possibly as an opportunity
to improve its international image
well of course i think that's quite
natural of course
but at this moment i think the focus is
really first
to uh
break to ensure that these countries
that are conflict conflicting each other
that they return to glo to the global
supply chain in order to mitigate the
the current food crisis that we are
suffering uh including in the southeast
asia region
uh and of course the second thing is to
make sure
that the the g20 is successful under
indonesia's chairmanship
okay that was lena alexandra the head of
the international relations department
at the center for strategic and
international studies in jakarta thank
you very much for your analysis
thank you